في الدراسه الاخيره التي قمنا بها في
مدينه الاسكندريه في مصر ونتيجه التغير في
التخطيط العمراني على مدى ادراك
المجتمعات العمرانيه الجديده بالمخاطر
البحريه هذه العواصف والنواه وغيره اكتشفت
ان 60% من سكان المناطق الجديده لا يعرفون
اي شيء عن المخاطر الساحليه وهم يعيشون في
اقدم مدينه ساحليه في حوض المتوسط فهنا
منطقه الاسكندريه منطقه يسكنها في هذه
المنطقه العمرانيه اكثر من عشره مليون شخص
منطقه منخفضه وفيها مجموعه من القنوات
المائيه التي تساعد في تصريف عمليات
المياه العواصف والامطار مثل طاهره
المحموديه التي ردمت اجزاء منها المصاب في
اسكندريه مما مما يؤدي الى
القدره على التعامل مع عاصفه مثل ما سبقت
هنا تجني الانسان على الطبيعه يد الانسان
ويد البشر كيف يمكن ان تزيد الوضع سوءا
بالتاكيد ان مسؤوليتنا هذا التغير المناخي
لم يكن ليكون بهذا الشكل المدمر ان لم يكن
سوء التخطيط العمراني هو اساس هذه المخاطر
الصوره بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي ما يمكن
للاسف ان تؤول اليه الامور مستقبلا ان لم
نتدارك الوضع هذا المشهد يوري دخول
العواصف الساحليه والدخول مياه البضاح في
الشريط الساحلي وما يتحول فيه المشهد في
حاله حدوث هذا وهذا نراه في الاسكندريه في
العواصف ما يحدث هو
الكارثه هو ان كل البنيه التحتيه والتحرك
في مناطق
الدمار التي التي ضمن الاعصار يصبح شبه مس
تحيل كان هناك تقرير منشور من ثلاث ايام
يتكلم ان الانتقال من
من الشرق للغرب
ياخذ وقت اربع ساعات في مسافه بضعه
كيلومترات فقط لماذا ان هذا هو المشهد
الذي يحصل في حاله البنيه التحتيه
والطرقات تقريبا بالكامل
[موسيقى]